qu'at-il donc en tête à quoi pensent ou
vladimir poutine les ukrainiens mais
aussi son propre peuple et le reste du
monde se pose ces questions le président
russe at il l'intention d'envahir
l'ukraine comme l'urss avait envahi
l'afghanistan il ya 40 ans veut-il
déloger le président zelensky du pouvoir
par la force et le remplacer par un
gouvernement à sa botte avant de se
retirer veut-il même aller encore plus
loin et s'attaquer à d'autres pays le
mystère poutine reste entier et ceux qui
l'ont côtoyé n'en dresse pas important
assurant on est entré en 1984 la même
année à la même école du kgb et
d'ailleurs c'est là où on peut déjà
citer une caractéristique quand on lui a
donné et sous-estiment le danger donc il
est dangereux pour lui il est dangereux
pour le service c'est pour ça d'ailleurs
qu'il a raté sa carrière d'espion on l'a
renvoyé alain gras et ça part de là
c'est à dire qu'il faut le prendre
vraiment au sérieux parce que il est
capable de tout malheureusement une
autre question reste à ce stade sans
réponse les sanctions imposées par la
communauté internationale peuvent-elles
un tant soit peu faire flancher le
maître du kremlin ça n'a jamais été le
cas ces dernières années que ce soit
après la guerre en géorgie
celle en syrie où les nombreux cas
d'empoisonnement d'opposants les
occidentaux et c'est cette fois de
frapper un peu plus fort et tente
notamment de paralysant partie la banque
centrale russe avec le gel de ses
réserves à l'étranger la réalité c'est
qu'elle aura beaucoup moins de réserve
donc elle va les utiliser avec
parcimonie et donc vraisemblablement on
devrait avoir un fort effondrement du
rouble dans les prochains jours la
banque centrale russe a d'ailleurs été
très clair elle s'attend un choc pour
l'économie russe si toutes les mesures
sont mises en place qu'ils soient
similaires 1991 1991 c'est bien sûr la
chute de l'urss
l'impact de cette mesure et des autres
sanctions prises pourraient avoir un
effet considérable sur l'économie russe
les occidentaux espèrent voir ainsi
certains piliers du pouvoir et une
partie de la population appelée poutine
à la raison pour éviter un effondrement
rien ne dit que vladimir poutine n'ira
pas au bout de ses projets pour autant